allez les cherry on va accueillir une
légende qui est prête il nous vivions
avec sa fille on est très net' tous
comme du parce que c'est une des plus
grandes stars clair la du sport voilà
vraiment c'est une légende tous les
lobbys des mecs comme ça il y en a cinq
yahia federer il ya michael jordan ya
tyson et voilà il ya ainsi on me sert
yamissi à nadal
et bien il est avec nous ce soir il y
avec sa fille millan mike tyson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
quel âge as-tu millan tata dix ans je
crois nine bonjour donc plus qu'à
regarder regardez regardez l anneau vont
regarder comme un loup c'est un truc de
ouf c'est mike qu'il entraîne elle est
fan de tennis tu vas être une énorme
championne et mike je suis très heureux
de te voir tu joue au tennis tu joues tu
yoplait et nsu avec une autre ici un peu
je t'ai vu tu aimais non non je les
côtoie tous les deux ok ok donc tu peux
me battre
un bar
[Rires]
à la parade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est lamentable et fort il a nous
inclus il a fait 544 laisse moi juste
pour le kiff en faire une au moins que
je vais dire que je tapais devant tout
le monde
[Rires]
un vrai mec
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup pour tout le monde je
dirige s'est fracassée mal mike tu la
coach je vais jouer contre ta fille les
gars je vais lancer une balle mon public
je vous le dis si milla ne bat la
personne repartira avec 5000 euros
d'accord similan perd malheureusement ce
sera perdu d'accord on fait ça en cinq
points accor millan il ya un petit cours
on a installé un petit cours dehors
ok on joue trois contre moi et c'est ton
papa qui va coacher hockey mike tu la
coach entre moi tu sais que j'étais
champion de tunisie mois que novak mais
si je gagne toute ta vie
dès que tu feras nine et dès que tu
seras quelque part tu diras je suis fort
mais le plus fort ça reste quand même
baba oui c'est ça un vrai t'as peur
c'est fait merci c'est fait
mais là on n'y vend trois points peppone
hockey fait pas de servir qu'à pas trop
faim c'est bon match et rim mike tu veux
lui dire un truc n'a toujours pas trop
fort parce qu'on la croit fort
et fais gaffe tu dors extrêmement
violent cette pétarade et la mapad mais
la balle à 100 m la foire elle dit karim
ghazi à 0 pour toi allez c'est parti
non c'est faux tu as il ya un partout
mais aussi j'ai moi aussi moi aussi j'ai
des enfants des gaffes dans un bon jour
trois points en trois points ok les
belges actuels et ben ouais de match
[Applaudissements]
mais la bonne voie mais l'outil
téléphonique j'adore graves ont bu la
tasse
c'est vrai quoi mike je veux jouer avec
elle avant de te plaît oui weaver
d'accord à roland garros je vais jouer
avec elle et là je peux te dire tu vas
voir tu veux montrer la vidéo parce que
là elle m'a elle m'a énervé qui peut
battre la famille tyson et ben on a vu
que ils sont très fort un sens rêver